we put out a pod every single week
consistently 52 weeks plus at this point
in a row we are putting out Clips every
single week on our social media pages
one a day one per platform yes same clip
same clip so we have same copy same clip
seven to nine posts a week that is
disproportionally the first place to
focus on attention is the number one
asset there's a bunch of things I want
to get into but I I do understand where
we are in you know a little bit of
limited time um so the first thing I
want to ask you is actually something
that I think applies to a lot of people
it's a little bit different than the
traditional question you're probably
asked uh but it very much applies to me
right now so I want to kind of look at
this as a consultation question straight
happy to do it we've been at this for 10
months um we're of the impression our
production definitely is top-notch
that's just a factual thing yep then we
have we're of the belief that we have
the sauce our F we our following is a
very very loyal following um but at the
end of the day we have been stuck at
12,000 Orthodox Jewish followers and
we've had on a lot of yeah it's not
exactly what I'm trying to do but like
within the community like people love us
yeah yeah yeah like we were just in
Israel over the holidays um and like
kids in the street yeah yeah for sure
and uh but at the end of the day we're
just like we've had on a lot of like
we've had on some very notable names but
we're not breaking out uh out of the
Jewish like the the regular Jewish
community and that's really what I'm
looking for right now that's literally
what I'm up against and I think that
probably how are you trying to so one of
the given how saturated the market is
obviously with content right now I felt
that good production would be an easy
controllable factor in order to uh move
us like kind of bring us more eyes
quicker and just jump out to the
subconscious while these guys are
legitimate um we're putting out uh we
put out a pod every single week
consistently 52 weeks plus at this point
in a row we are putting out Clips every
single week on our social media Pages
how much one a day on all social at
least one a day on one per platform yes
same clip same clip so we have copy same
clip seven to nine posts a week and we
post on that is disproportionately the
first place to focus on okay you know
the reality is is organic social is now
foundational to awareness especially
with the way the algorithms are going
you genuinely actually are one Tik Tock
clip away from quadrupling your audience
though that's much harder than it was 36
months ago but it's but it's not
impossible so if you're making a clip
for
social you're putting yourself in a
vulnerable spot because you're not
making the clip for the distribution so
you can imagine given the community and
me knowing a little bit about it if if
you're speaking to a room full of people
in Brooklyn uh in the community that
might be a different speech than if you
went to Babson and spoke to the students
at Babson about entrepreneurship it
would be different you would use less
yish words you would have different
references it would be contextual the
fact that you're taking a single clip
and then posting that on Instagram
Twitter Facebook Tik Tok LinkedIn I I I
I got to find out from you which ones
but immediately as you can imagine a
heavily you know um hidic joked out
referenced out talk in Alabama at a
Walmart isn't going to land the same way
and by taking a clip and posting the
same thing on Twitter that you're
posting on Instagram they won't land the
same way so the biggest mistake people M
make in Social is they look at it as
purely distribution and they just want
to put something out on it and they want
it to go out when in reality
understanding best practices creatively
and analytically per
platform is imperative for you to break
out got it um if you're post if you want
to win Tik Tok for example you have to
respect Tik Tok just like you being part
of this community you know when people
come from the outside and and try to
sell the community yeah you're laughing
already it's impossible if they're not
respectful to the context or the tone
you're saying diversify what we're
putting out tailor make it to each
audience ready for this this production
is incredible I would mail this in in
return if I could get you to give this
level of financial Vigor and emphasis on
what time you post what the copy is
where you post and uping your output
across the seven platforms that matter
I'm about this life this is amazing but
this is
wildly enormously secondary for you to
get awareness to proper social media
strategy around the creative per
platform no that makes a lot of sense so
my my only qu my first of all a lot of
one thing another thing is live I'm
devastated that I'm too busy to be a
streamer I'm going to say that nice and
slow for Dustin what I am devastated
that I am too busy to be a streamer I
have told the story over and over of
Twitter and YouTube being the foundation
of the Gary V brand which is absolutely
true that 2006 to 2010 moment was real I
had forgotten actually forgotten that
the six or nine months that I was really
flirting somewhat aggressively not as
consistent as Twitter and YouTube with
you stream which in essence is twitch
and kick and Tik Tok live right now I
forgot how big that was I believe that
if I had time and wasn't actually
running businesses and was actually
doing the Gary ve thing that I think
most people think I do for a living
right I would probably stream for 12
hours a day oh really I would and so the
other thing to think about is your live
strategy you know I think the depths
that come along with audience engagement
in live and streaming is profound you're
much more interactive no longer are they
consuming they're you feel like part of
it it's more social relationship you
sound like also you're making a big uh
distinction between live and vlogging
right those two SE vlogging is episodic
was huge for me definitely another you
know there'll be a time where I get a
little older and I'll sum it all up and
I'll talk about the chapters of growth
daily V will be in there it's huge for
me no I'm talking about streaming and
live got it so one one last thing on
this topic is so we have been very
focused on putting out content that is
not just Orthodox based like that's app
to the whole world course if you want to
go broad right but it sounds like what
you're saying is that we have to respect
the individual platforms that one I'm
getting that correctly and also slang
right like all of us are going to act
differently in this room than we would
act if we all met up for a business
meeting a to at midnight right there's a
different slightly different version of
us that's how these platforms are the
words the slang even the content you
make things that are trending things
that are in the know Tik tok's a little
bit younger than Instagram Instagram's
Facebook's a little older than Instagram
all three of those need slightly
different things you know even within
the athetic community well you're
posting on Facebook should be really
crushing for the 70-year-old yentas more
so than the 16-year-old you guys coming
up do you think we should but but is
trying to get
everyone uh not as would you say the
niche like I I always here keep your
audience as as niche as possible your
opening question was to Broad in your
audience no but I'm saying outside like
our main focus is 18 to 35 you know just
in the world that well good I mean
that's an old television thing right you
guys are all in this pocket 18 and 35
are like two different human beings
right different slang different interest
talk to each other anymore yeah so I
think I think the biggest obvious thing
that will help you dramatically is if
you reverse it I believe what's
happening between production value and
this show is that you're putting an
enormous amount of emphasis to this
which I love it's
important but it but you're viewing like
most people you're viewing social as a
distribution instead of like an actual
place to like really cultivate it's like
you're like using like email press send
get out there find us instead of like
really understanding how to do that
super well I think two to three posts a
day on all the platforms face Facebook's
a monster people continue to
underestimate it then there's Facebook
infeed then there's Facebook reals
there's Instagram infeed there's
Instagram reals there's Instagram
stories like there's so much how big of
an editing team do you think you need to
put out the consistent amount of once
you understand let's just say the
actually what each platform is NE needed
it all depends on how you do it I mean
you know where you're at in your careers
now I believe that there's because I get
five emails a day from 17-year-olds in
the community willing to work for free
if you had so many kids roll up on you
on Israel I have a feeling you could
have three tomorrow for an internship
and pay them minimum wage or put them on
or give them experience right you know
it all depends on how much it costs what
you know you get an editor from Disney
they're going to cost you $200,000 that
means you have none you get three kids
at 17 that are good at it to build an
Orthodox Jewish Army of editors it's
it's it's really real talk like like
we've we've taken it you know Dustin
knows like we used to do it all here now
but I have a global global Creator
editor Team all over the world costs are
different time zones we want to be 24/7
but the mistake people make is they will
buy these I've never had these lights in
my career right which by the way again I
do not want to demonize it cuz I think
it's [__] epic but to me it's
secondary to getting people to know who
the [__] you are yeah I agree with you
100% and you're making the discrepancy
between the distribution and the
engagement meaning we're looking at it
is like distribution will give us the
opportunity to get engagement rather
than the actual content that we're
putting out is going to be what is
engaging by tlor making it Tik Tok
that's right away from everything
changing I'm an extremely focused
aggressive just bottom line type of
human being and you're ambitious and
hungry and focused and driven yes okay I
would say those things are very much
true me too and I'm for me one of my
biggest challenges is working with a
team and being like more so to speak
gentle if you all want to call it with
them so this way like my most people
honestly can't handle the intensity yeah
so well the
intensity is probably not a problem to
handle okay it's potentially the
combativeness the lack of self
the empathy the comp like it's the other
soft skills intensity is incredibly easy
to deal with when it's intense love and
safety and and deliciousness well said
you know intensity is not the energy is
not the issue all right guys that's it
I'm uh but you know it's funny brother
you're how old are you I'm 29 yeah bro
you're such a young man like this is
where you need to make some
decisions um you know you need couple
things I think this I I I'm excited
we're going here you have to make make
some decisions at 29 and you have plenty
of time you can make these decisions at
39 too but by the time you get to 39
you're going to want to make this
decision which is the following how
would you like it to be meaning there is
an incredibly obvious correlation on
this which is likeability what you're
actually bringing to everyone around you
like there's many ways to build the
biggest building in town I you know I
say this a lot if you watch my content
maybe you've heard this like either you
just have the talent to build the
biggest buildings or you spend your time
tearing down else everyone else's
building and your building is actually
not that big right my belief system is
when one excuses their behavior on
things like ambition or driven or
focus and don't really break it down to
its pure form which is what is it that
you're thinking when you're too intense
for them is it that you believe if you
pay someone that they owe you this is an
incredible challenge for people that are
bosses I don't believe just because I
pay Dustin that that gives me cart
blanch to make it not good to make what
not good is like to be an [__] you're
saying yeah of course not you know what
I mean obviously and and [__] comes
in a lot of shapes and sizes like even
just the way you're talking I don't
believe that you're like blindly on the
side of like being a dick face but you
know I can't speak for that you know I
think I think the thing to Think Through
is like a dick elbow he's not here's a
good one for example it is incredibly
clear
that most people governments parents
bosses humans love using fear to get
things done right it's easy it's cheap
it's quick and it is 100% of where
resentment comes
from right so I think a lot about that
you know and so like the question
becomes like how would you like it to
play out like would you like to have
$100 million but very few people like
you would you is it better to have $80
million not a 100 but everyone loves you
some people don't give a [__] maybe you
could have 500 million if you do it
properly and play the long game there's
a there's a million ways right is is it
is it dollars is it like what does bring
the joy I'll give you an example what's
really intriguing about me to me is I
just love the
game like like I'll take the money but
it's crazy by comparison to a lot of
contemporaries my relationship with the
money is very different I totally heard
that it's like the trading cards game
with you and like the honestly for me
the garage yeah bro the garage sale
stuff is such a [__] preview into my
soul like I'm genuinely actually
genuinely no [__] more excited to
find a $2 item in a garage sale in New
Jersey that's worth 38 bucks on eBay
than when I do a $7 million deal here at
Boehner and it's not even close what's
so what's the difference but what's
those what's the difference in those two
The Thrill of the hunt the why is The
Hunt of making that deal let's say the
one that got you more money not as
enjoyable because there's no surprise
here got it you know like the element of
the game like and just even like the
pride I have in like knowing like The
Knowing is really exciting last thing
Gary in your pursuit of success yes is
there anything that you have done that
you have regretted cuz it's difficult of
course I spent my entire 20s working in
a liquor store 97 hours a week and did
nothing I was say more morally but why
more morally like when you when when you
no because because I don't want I don't
need anything from anyone oh yeah maybe
made a mistake I don't know 35 I don't
really think a small mistake I don't
think lack of cander and firing people
without setting them up properly I'm not
sure if that's a
moral I don't know if I put that in the
category subjectively judging myself if
I did something morally wrong I'm
embarrassed that I didn't have the
emotional strength to be more upfront
with people the counter to like when I'm
like saying oh you know what I admire
from people that my dad even though he
delivered it like a [__] very
inappropriately I respected that he shot
it straight but everyone felt like [__]
right that was a weakness of my cander
was my biggest weakness ironically Gary
ve the public figure crushes cander but
one-on-one if I start caring about you I
[__] I I struggle delivering so
morally I've never like stole someone's
money or like I I just never here's the
thing unlike a lot of other ambitious
people I had such a great mother that I
didn't need it for my self-esteem I
needed it for to I'm actually do you
know what I've come to realize I'm just
curious of how good I
am to me this is one big game of
curiosity right like I'm trying to just
figure out when it's all said and done
like where did I rank where the chips
going yeah like it's a game no I totally
get that to me most people look for
Success it's a dollar sign yeah as a
badge to leverage against right it's why
why people buy Mercedes it's why people
wear Louis Vuitton it's it's all [__]
badging I don't have a car you know it's
a Gucci p on the
train but I I really I really believe
it's social signaling often to hide an
insecurity um other times people just
genuinely love fashion and they
genuinely love driving the car but I
think a lot about the world from a
selfish selfless standpoint like we
touched on and then the other biggest
thing I think is confidence and security
I think if you look at those four things
and you really look at them you can get
the answers to almost everything one
last thing how do you have so much
confidence in your
goodness because I have [__] 45 years
of looking at it because I see it in my
son when somebody trips during a game he
can't help but just stop even though he
wants to win it's in him I got lucky do
you think I'm you know when people talk
about luck I don't talk about luck with
money I talk about luck of what my
personality played out to be I just have
natural compassion I know I'm nice like
a good mom man I have a great mom and I
also had great DNA and then I also got
great circumstances I got a lot of [__]
out sounds Jewish yeah it's true though
but you know this where my mom did well
that a lot of cliche Jewish moms don't
do well is but she H be accountable you
know that delusion when you're like
you're good at everything and you're
always right that [__] doesn't work yeah
yeah that [__] doesn't work you know
what my mom did was like you're the best
but when I did wrong [__] she punched me
in the face like actually like kind of
like really 80s style plus I grew up in
the 80s in the'80s when I had issues
here's a nice Jewish name when I fought
odad winin stock three times between
third and sixth grade I learned how to
deal with conflict [__] Winestock you
know me and odad fought like I you know
like we were in in it it was a different
world we're now all in our kids [__]
kids can't [__] breathe without their
parents fighting every battle for them
paying for everything it's all [__]
out of whack it's like you know that you
have the confidence because you know
that you've gone through cuz I've been
on my own two feet cuz I don't need
anybody emotionally or financially do
you know what it feels like to not need
anyone emotionally or financially that's
life there is nothing
else most people are not fortunate
enough to have both down Gary thank you
so much I really apprciate Gary thank
you I
[Music]
appreciate